- The power of a group
of women skating together
is freedom charged.
It's just so empowering.
Yeah, it's amazing.
(energetic music)
My name is Valeria Kechichian
and I'm the co-founder and director
of Longboard Girls Crew.
Longboard Girls Crew is an
international longboard community
that supports and promotes
women in action sports.
It's trying to shift the
way women are perceived
by society, by the industry
and mostly by themselves.
The way the industry has been showing us
it's like in a really sexualized way.
The main thing that is missing for women
in the action sports industry is exposure.
Sometimes, we need to see
someone else doing something
to believe that we also can.
We started it with a friend
in Madrid back in 2010.
At first we wanted to get
more girls into the sport
'cause it was really male
dominated and we realized
when the two or three
girls that skated in Madrid
we got together, the
energy was so different
from when we skated with boys.
So we wanted to create
more of those moments.
I thought, "Why don't we shoot a video
of all these girls skating together?"
After the first video,
everything kind of exploded a little bit
and the video became viral.
We portray women all shapes
and colors, sizes, religion.
The response of women was immediate
and the movement just grew worldwide.
Longboard Girls Crew is
in more than 80 countries.
It's really, it's really beautiful
to get all these emails
from around the world
from women telling us how
they started longboarding
because of one of our
videos or for the movement.
What I want women to see when
they see Longboard Girls Crew
is that they can do it, too.
It doesn't matter how you look
and it doesn't matter
what you've been told
is for girls or is for boys.
You can do anything.
(energetic music)